[Music] Hello,
welcome to Econoclast.
We are pleased to present
a new multidisciplinary think tank. Our
objective is
simple: to provide you with clear
and concise arguments that you won't
find in the mainstream, so that
you can develop your own
scenarios and
better understand the
economic news around us. We
wanted to come together in this think
tank to democratize access to
economic and geopolitical information,
allowing the public to access
information without
ideological bias or prejudice, with integrity, so that
everyone can form their
own opinion. We will work
on four main areas. The first is
the democratization of
economic concepts. This involves highlighting
certain paradoxes that most
analysts blithely overlook, paradoxes that
need to be brought to light and
confronted with
realities that are often not what is
presented to you. The second thing is
financial analysis—
financial, economic, and
macroeconomic analysis—and  Geopolitics and
politics, and trying to give you a
different perspective. The third point is
foresight, meaning putting in place
a number of scenarios that will
allow you to anticipate things a
little better than you do now. And the fourth point is
solutions. We will try to
find solutions together to
protect your assets, to
explain how to live in the world
that awaits us. So, as you understand,
we have decided to think
seriously, but without falling into
the trap of being overly serious or
dispensing revealed truths.
Our credo is
field experience. We have each had
the opportunity to travel extensively, to
immerse ourselves in
very heterogeneous economic and geopolitical realities.
We have gathered
experiences that we have compared, and
we have arrived at
conclusions that are often disconcerting. This is what
we hope to share with
you. But sharing also means
welcoming new profiles,
new skills. In other words,
the econoclasts are enriched by
diversity. Find us on
[Music]
laconoclast.fr